why did the anime makers of my hero put
my hero in fortnite King
is the anime not dope the anime is out
right now that's why because they wanted
people to play that game and see it it's
like yo where'd this character come from
it's the anime dope why what why are
they putting IPS in fortnite
strategically around when the game
actually comes out when the movie
actually the anime dope two games ain't
dope I'm just saying this you keep don't
attach it to fortnite don't don't attack
people do the same thing they put it in
there to get consistent looks on that
character to help sell the movie all
right you think they push stuff like
Spider-Man to come out around the game
perform so why can't you take that same
mentality in